the Joe Rogan experience there were a
lot of good things that's the reason I
met Thomas how'd he find you guys
he found Tom through his assistant
Charlie yep and when I met when I met
you it was at a show yeah opening I was
the best it was I was the emcee he was
the middle Bert was the middle and J was
the headliner
yeah and immediately within like [ __ ]
five seconds Tom bonded like within five
[ __ ] seconds I remember he walked in
and then he goes at four to state game
was on Tom's watch at Florida State game
and Tom's like oh come on
Jay's like the [ __ ] is this and I go oh
you watch before stakes I went there
sounds like yeah he's like he got money
on it and Tom's like yeah I got a
hundred bucks on it he's like you're
making [ __ ] 50 bucks tonight as a
host what kind of [ __ ] a to you
walked out and I was like look at Tom
ago hey welcome to the dorm I so nerd it
out that he went to FSU that was like he
went to FSU he's like yeah went there
for like 15 years
what and then I go when and then he
tells me the I go oh you you guys want a
national championship went over there
and I was like hey so was like I just
mentioned like a player I don't know
whatever I was like with Derrick Brooks
there he was like oh I don't know I
don't know anything no no what you don't
[ __ ] know the guys name I think this
is what made you laugh when I Derrick
Brooks was a big player of Florida State
right him work done when I was in my
senior year of college I went to the gas
station and they had a single cassette
single of Brooks & Dunn and I went oh
wow our two biggest players released a
single got thora this has got to be good
right I'm a big fan of hip hop so I
bought the single of Brooks & Dunn not
realizing it's a country western band
they they weren't big yet and I put it
in and it was country music and I went
so Derrick Brooks have worked on made a
country album that's interesting oh my
and I listened to the whole [ __ ]
thing was like I was like one song I was
like this is not bad I'm a fan of the
guys I'm a fan
yeah I'm in I'm in and I think I told
you that you were like Brooks & Dunn is
not work Brooks and you
College yeah yeah did you go did I go
yeah he was gorgeous back then you
dropped out yeah you went all the way
through and then some kinda all the way
I had to take prison classes and in New
York what's I mean so is before the
internet so you would if you didn't
finish GED you would you had to send in
to the state of Florida and say I want
to finish college and they give you the
books that they give you the prisoners
send them to me in New York I just had
to read the books of my peers yeah like
it's no like if you want to get a
college course in prison they send you
the books and you just do the work
basically you what just fill it out just
basically I got the books and I got the
tests and I just had to fill out the
test do you ever wonder like if you were
in prison like how much [ __ ] you'd get
done alright you'd get like really fit
you like I do I wasn't a good fit all
day sit-ups I would let so many bricks
yes I would into a rape you're like you
guys are gonna rape me they're like well
we weren't even thinking about that but
now that you brought it up seem like we
can yeah you seem pretty soft yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]